we're looking towards the last month of
2021 and it's time for a look at the
year in retrospect so for today's video
we're going to be looking at the top
anime fights this year as always 2021
came with an assortment of fights that
wowed us and dazzled us all either
through hype or just insane animation
and editing techniques i'll be counting
down on what i think are the 10 best
anime fights for 2021 so far i've made
several videos on this throughout the
year so let's see who's making the cut
now
dai versus baron is what i'd call an
underrated gem kind of like the show
where it came from it truly harkens back
to the days of old with shonen battles
and all those battle auras and a lot of
shouting it does give the whole 90s feel
with a lot of polish made for the modern
era and i enjoyed the fight because it
really unlocks some memories of my
childhood much like the modern dragon
ball anime 2. the pacing of the battle
is great and the voice acting really
puts this one over the hump not a lot of
people i know have been watching the
dragon quest anime but i think it's a
worthwhile journey with a lot of fights
like this will the dragon quest anime be
something that fits the bill for a good
shonen watch well try it out and see if
you like it at least now you know that
somewhere in there is a banger of a
fight
next we have toru versus elma on the
list
seriously did anyone expect this out of
dragon maid of all things kyoni is not
exactly the studio well known for hype
inducing fights filled with intensity
and special effects dragon maid's an
anime that's a comedic slice of life
that's more known for both its
wholesomeness and fan services elements
then we get one of the most unexpected
yet insane fights i've seen this year i
mean really just look at this battle
it's got some animation techniques and
effects that will put a lot of modern
anime fights to shame i also loved how
the two of them went to each other with
such intensity you'd expect something
like this out of some well-produced
action shows and not a slice of life
where the dragons spend most of the time
being adorable just a fair warning that
as cute as these dragons look they're
all virtually weapons of mass
destruction a clash between two of them
wouldn't be pretty and this fight is
proof of that
we proceed with asta and yami versus
dante
it's such a joy watching black clover's
journey in a way it kind of reflects the
shonen protagonist growth doesn't it
starting off the black sheep of the
bunch but slowly and surely earning her
love and admiration for the plot that
became more and more engaging oh and of
course there's the fighting as well lots
of cool fights and in this final arc of
the anime we have this banger i've
always loved yummy as a character and he
just oozes coolness with whatever he
does and this fight definitely showcases
that but even the most badass mentor has
that plucky hero to guide with how yami
carried the first part of the fight
before asta comes in with the finish it
just shows that great mentor-student
relationship that i've come to enjoy in
these shonen shows the two have a cool
dynamic and i love seeing it all the way
to the last arc if you've put off
watching black clover then maybe this
would be a fight to get you back into it
it's definitely worth the journey
carmilla vs isaac makes its way to the
list
i've talked lots of good stuff about
castlevania and even though looking at
what we've already had this year this
fight does still hold up in the bigger
picture of things this is one of the
better fight choreographies in the
battles that are featured so far it may
not be too high budget or as fluid as
some of the big titans of the anime
battles go but the pacing is on point
back in my previous video that featured
this encounter i said that i placed it
high because of its role in showing off
character development i still stand by
that now and i'd say that a good fight
should also exhibit character there are
some haphazardly written fights but you
can really feel the personalities and
the development shine with how the
combatants battled in this one it's
understandable that people sleep on
castlevania but it's a pretty good anime
well the latter is in a technical sense
oh boy one of my favorite fights to talk
about i think that when the dust settled
2021 will have vivi as one of my main
landmarks in the world of anime sure
it's not going to be the most talked
about show nor would it likely be the
first thing that people think of when
you say 2021 several years down the line
still among new anime that started
airing this year anime watchers would
likely look back with nostalgic eyes
towards this sci-fi hit for me the main
attraction of the series isn't even in
the fighting which makes this fight even
more amazing if you look at the context
phoebe's a show that doesn't primarily
sell itself on fights but for the
animators to go all out and give us this
amazing encounter is really something
there's a lot of combat insanity in vv
but this one just takes the cake this is
the one that got me very very hyped and
chock full of adrenaline when watching
the best part about including this entry
will have more insanity like this after
the break if you've been enjoying this
video so far perhaps those like and
subscribe buttons up there are just
looking a little bit more attractive
right yeah i'm encouraging you to
subscribe and hit the bell button so you
can get notifications whenever i upload
a new video thanks for listening to this
short intermission now let's get back to
the show
[Music]
[Music]
at the time of this writing tact of
destiny still has quite a long run to go
so why don't we look at the first
episode fight after all first
impressions are ever so important aren't
they entering a season i know that many
people didn't have high expectations
from tack top destiny it's part of a
game promotion first secondly people
have brushed it off as waifu bait since
that's pretty much the name of the game
now with mobile games waifu gacha
collecting but this fight really blew me
away honestly then again what else did i
expect it's mad house and mapper and if
they want to sell a video game they
better do a damn good job with the anime
adaptation and a good job they did with
this astounding display of effects
goosebump inducing transformation
sequences and display of fireworks and
sheer destruction first impressions are
very important and let's just say that
tact of destiny impressed me so much in
the first episode for me to have this
fight as one of the best in 2021
following that is naruto vs ishiki
ah the baryon mode fight as i like to
call it it's a fight that got all the
naruto fans evolved back into the thick
of things and quite a bittersweet swan
song perfect combination for a fight
which serves as naruto's final blaze of
glory the whole fight kept me on the
edge of my seat due to how impactful
each attack seemed the production for
this scene is top-notch as it should be
for such an important moment ishiki has
more than proven himself in battle
before so seeing naruto start to get the
advantage on him was such a cathartic
moment like a lot of modes in anime
barrion mode does have a drastic
drawback and it set the stage for what i
feel like is one of the most emotional
scenes in boruto yes one of the most
emotional moments in boruto involves
naruto and gurama it's an emotional
farewell for fuckurama that follows an
eye-popping display of shonen powers no
wonder many people have been so excited
to see this fight animated
the final capped off a long world wind
of a ride putting a fitting end to one
of the best shown end franchises there
is for me it's especially hard on an
emotional level it's a whole culmination
of a long journey and utsuro serves as
the perfect final antagonist overall
this fight had a lot of impact on me i
won't outright put it up as one of those
fights that will change how you see
anime forever or anything outrageous
like that but it's a damn good fight
that will live on in history as a solid
finale to gintamar
[Music]
i'd say that mapa really put themselves
on the map these past few years didn't
they first taking over the production of
attack on titan then being the ones
behind jiu jitsu kaizen's awesome battle
scenes jiu jitsu kaizen has a lot of
noteworthy battles but this one by far
is my favorite team fights are good if
you can see the chemistry and the
synergy between the fighters and with
how yuji and todo fought together you
can really see their dynamic in full
display it's a mentored disciple type
battle not too unlike the yami and asked
the one a while ago but with the full
benefit of marpa's breathtaking
animation and while gojo didn't
participate much until the closing
moments that hallo purple was still
super amazing truly wowed the whole fan
base then and it is something for us to
remember no one's sleeping on jiu jitsu
kaizen anytime soon and it's easy to see
why
did i cheat on this one well it got
recapped anyway in the 2021 demon slayer
anime so we're gonna count it anyway i
mean it's just the most hype fight in
the mainstream coming into as far back
as 2020 when demon slayer's movie got
announced and when it finally did hit
theaters it proved that the hype was
worth it that's pretty much a staple
with ufo table fights i mean unlimited
budget works and all due to um reasons
whichever method you choose to enjoy the
fight though you'll just be amazed by
how rain goku and akaza's techniques are
put on display i expect a lot out of the
person with the title of fire pillar and
you do have to see him fight to truly
experience what his powers are like what
makes this fight a winner is the
emotional weight it carried i know you
guys would have probably gotten tired of
people flooding the airwaves while
hyping up demon slayer fights and ufo
table animation but when you look at it
this fights more than just flashy
effects and animation the emotional
aspect of this fight is also an
extremely underappreciated part of it
and i think that this makes this one
even better than the famed rui fight
so in addition to showing you some of
the most amazing masterpieces the anime
world has given us this year i hope that
i've introduced you to some anime that
you're on the fence with picking up
there's a lot of spectacular fights to
be enjoyed and some of them might have
even been in shows that you haven't even
bothered with before i close i'd like to
encourage you to check out my other
social media i have a patreon and you
can also try channel memberships also
follow my instagram if you prefer to be
notified of the latest news about my
channel there as well as enjoy some
anime tidbits that's gonna be it for
today thanks for watching and i'll see
you again stay strong and stay awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you